hi everyone
um thanks for the introduction
um again my name is Ethan O'Malley I
work at Bluebird bio and I'm the head of
the technical documentation at Bluebird
and you might ask you know what is
technical documentation but for the
long and short of it is I do anything to
get the bla submitted and approved any
of the documentation internally as well
as the regulatory documentation so
module 3 compiling all the module 3
documentation working with the CMC teams
and the CMOS to get that compiled
also after we've submitted the
application then responding to uh
information requests from the agency and
getting the sites ready for their
inspections
this is
a lot of work in normal times
um it's it's a it's a lot of uh you know
those who've lived to it no it's it's
extreme amount of work
um and it's a hard and normal times but
uh during the past couple years and with
with the pandemic it's been even more
challenging and so I want to pass on
some of the learnings and experiences
that that we've had at Bluebird to help
you with your next application and or
inspection
so I want to start with a story about
being prepared and uh
I grew up in California San Francisco to
be exact and I have a love of Nature and
so did my father and he taught me to
enjoy uh camping and backpacking
um in the Sierra mountains and so he
taught me really early on to
um you know what to do to be prepared if
we ran across a bear basically because
we know in California and there's a lot
of bears and if you're going to go
backpacking in their backyard inevitably
you'll run that cross one and so you
want to be prepared so one of the golden
rules he taught me was to store your
food away from where you're sleeping so
don't store food where you're sleeping
and and then also if you do come across
a bear you have to stay calm and don't
do anything you know drastic and
um just pay attention so
um fast forward a few years you know as
I got older I was a you know ambitious
teenager and I took a bunch of my
friends camping into Yosemite National
Park and Yosemite is known for Bears
the first night we're there I prepared
the campsite I was the most experienced
camper I prepared the campsite and had
everything ready and we went to sleep
and then my buddy woke me up at like you
know two o'clock in the morning and said
Ethan there's a bear in the camp what do
we do and I grabbed my flashlight and
shined it out and there was two bdis
staring back at me and I could see the
bear and I and I told everybody I said
don't worry you know the bear just wants
the food let's just you know let him be
keep an eye on them and uh you know and
let them be and sure enough the bear
eventually went away in in the night we
woke up in the morning time and went and
expected what the bear did and The Bear
Went got rid of excuse me the bear
grabbed about half of our food but again
we were prepared we we had brought extra
food
um and we hadn't slept near the food so
we were safe and everything was good so
we had a good story to tell and and
everything was fine
so
um that's my story about preparation
preparation is you know is is being
prepared for what happens if and uh and
that's why I want to
talk to you today about preparing for an
inspection share some of my experiences
with with our recent inspections so
you'll be prepared when um when the FDA
comes calling and uh and you're ready
for it
so the agenda today I'm going to go over
some background of that you know
um the inspection background what our
product is what part of the agent
we are working with particularly with
the FDA
the learnings that we gathered from the
inspection both from a pre-inspection
perspective both from the sponsor and
the CMO as well as what we learned at
the inspection itself and then and then
the conclusions and takeaways
um all of this happened during you know
a pandemic so there are some things that
I will highlight that I thought were
interesting that maybe as a result of
the pandemic and weren't necessarily of
regular times
but I'll give away a little bit of a
punch line the punch line is be prepared
for a lot of granular detail from the
FDA the FDA has asked for a lot of
information to be filed in the bla
itself and then they've been using the
information request to actually even ask
for more detail and a lot more detail
from the CMOS more than we've expected
in the past
um and this may be a combination of two
things it may be a combination of the
fact that we're in the gene therapy
space and this is new to the FDA
um so they're not 100 sure
um what's important and what's not
important so they're asking for
everything
um or it also may be a fact that they've
asked for all this information because
it was during a pandemic and they um and
they wanted to use essentially the the
art of the virtual visit and ask for all
this information that they normally
would get if they had been on site so
they just asked for a lot more granular
detail even before they stepped foot on
the facility
um and uh that's that was interesting
that was that was new to us and again it
may be because we're in gene therapy or
maybe because uh the result of coping or
the pandemic itself
so information background the who what
and why
so we'll start with the uh the what
so Bluebird uh is
um a gene therapy company we do ex Vivo
lvv Manufacturing
and uh it starts with
um the plasmids we we manufacture our
plasmids all of our manufacturing is
takes place with with CMOS so there's
there's multiple contract manufacturers
the two manufacturers I'm going to focus
on today in today's presentation are our
lbv manufacturer and then our drug
substance drug product manufacturer but
the process starts with plasmids we
manufacture plasmids and then we
transfect the
HEK 293 T cells to produce our
lentiviral Vector with the plasmids
genetic material of Desire
um
in parallel or at the time when we need
drug product we actually collect
hpca cells for the patient
and then along with their Lev we
transduce those um patient cells and
transfer the genome material into those
patient cells and then formulate it and
then ultimately it's infused back into
the patient
um to for the drug that drug product is
infused back into the patient so um we
use multiple contract manufacturers
along the way but the ones that I'll be
talking today are the lvv manufacturer
and then the drug substance drug product
manufacturer
oh and then one thing of interest is
that the main thing about
contract manufacturers is it's good to
use contract manufacturers because you
don't have to you know maintain the
facility you don't have to have
um have to have all that infrastructure
and overhead but the one thing you give
up as most people know is control and uh
control and access access to the
facility Etc and that interestingly
enough was challenging during during
covid because as we know with covid
there were restrictions both
restrictions at sites and travel
restrictions and Etc and having that
lack of control was a little bit more
challenging during the pandemic
um than in other years so
thank you
so the who so part of the agency that we
work with so we're working with um
sieber we are obviously a gene therapy
product so we're working with the office
of tissue and advanced therapies uh
within sieber and then the other office
that we work with obviously is the
compliance of biologics office and the
dmpq division
um you know manufacturing a product
quality they're doing the the
inspections of the sites themselves so
this is the the part of the agency that
we're working with
foreign
why are we getting inspected well we're
getting inspected because we submitted a
bla we actually submitted two Blas
um we have two products
um they're both manufactured at both uh
facilities so both the lbv manufacturer
and the drug substance or product
manufacturer manufacture both products
for us
and um and so we submitted a bla and so
we need to do a pre-licensing inspection
and uh as as this comes out of the
verbiage right from the FDA page but uh
you know inspection of a new or existing
facility to manufacture a new biological
product and that's a pli one of my pet
peeves is when people mix up p p l i and
Pai
um so in this case we're talking about
pre-licensing inspection which is
actually getting the approval of the
product and then we also had another
inspection that we dealt with during
this during this time and that was a GMP
so one of the facilities the drug
substance drug product manufacturer has
already been inspected by the FDA and
they were up for their biannual
inspection so that's a GMP inspection so
the two types of inspections I'll be
talking today are the pli and the GMP
inspection
foreign
oh by the way I just note that uh if you
hear me clearing my floater a lot I'm
actually just getting over covid right
now
um so I might be a little stuffy and a
little sound a little funny so I
apologize for that but I'm just getting
over coveted and I'm fine by the way
um all right so the inspection so what
happened
um so as I said we
um we have two of our manufacturers were
being inspected we have the lvv
manufacturer and the drug substance drug
product manufacturer
um again both products were manufactured
at both sites
um there are they are both us-based
sites
um these sites had not been commercially
approved for you know basically for the
product that we're doing for gene
therapy or any other similar gene
therapy
um they were the sites that we used for
our clinical commercial manufacturing
although the clinical and Commercial
manufacturing may have not been
manufactured in the same building so it
was the same company it was the same
compound or the same facility but it
wasn't necessarily the same building so
we did do clinical and Commercial
manufacturing there but we you know they
were done in different buildings or
different sites within the compound
um the lbb manufacturer was was not all
that experienced um so we had to spend a
lot of time with them
um getting them ready to um
for the inspection and then letting them
know what what to expect and uh when you
know what to expect basically so we had
to work with them a lot the other site
the drug substance drug product facility
was a lot had a larger infrastructure
behind it so they had a larger company
that had broad manufacturing experience
and they could leverage that and they
did use that to come in they brought in
um
other people with from their
organization to help them get ready for
the facility for the audit and uh not
the audit sorry for the inspection and
and get them ready for Audits and things
like that so
all right
so
prior to the inspection what did we do
so you know the first thing
um that we did and the site did was do
mock mock audits
um we would go there you know our the
sponsor Bluebird would go there inspect
the site audit the site you know come up
with findings
um relay those filings to the site and
then resolve them
um one of the best things that that they
did was hire outside Consultants so both
facilities hired their own outside
consultant and had them do basically a
mock a mock audit pretend like they were
the FDA come in and review it and this
was um this was very good
um and they learned a lot because the
outside Consultants really treated
themselves like you know FDA reviewers
and they went down rabbit holes looked
at deviations really pressed the pressed
the CMO on you know why they made
certain decisions why they considered
something you know a minor deviation or
a major deviation Etc
um and so those were those were very
very helpful and very good for both
um for us and for for them and and they
shared those those findings with us
which was very helpful so we could um
then prepare because that was very good
for us to prepare of possible area is
which were weak or possibly weak before
the FDA got in there
the next thing obviously that was done
is you know practice runs so we did
water runs or media runs just to see how
the facility operated
Etc and those were
useful to a point but the one that was
the most useful is when we actually did
a mock product run and what they call
the pli demonstration run
and this
I thought was extremely helpful for both
us and the facility so one interesting
thing about you know our our gene
therapy product it's the low volume
product we we're not uh we're going
after very
um
you know orphan drug applications rare
diseases Etc so
um so we don't manufacture a lot of
batches at the facility so the fact that
the facility itself doesn't have a lot
of manufacturing experience with our
product
and with the fact that um there's there
has been there's a lot of new Personnel
coming on to the to the facility whether
it's new Personnel sitting in because of
um because of the pandemic maybe because
they're out sick or they've got a cover
or you have Personnel
um coming in because there's just been a
high turnover rate as we know during the
pandemic there was a lot of uh you know
High turnover at facilities and even at
our sponsor even at Bluebird there was a
lot of turnover so the fact that you had
a lot of new personnel
not who didn't have a lot of experience
running the process it having these mock
demonstration runs was was really
important
um and we learned a lot prior to the FDA
getting there so um so those were those
were very useful and uh very informative
for both uh sponsor for us and for on
the CMO
um
the other thing that we did you know
prior to the inspection and preparing
for it was was have meetings now in
normal times or non-pandemic times we
would have had much more face-to-face
meetings
um you know
being on site get everyone together in a
room get all the key personnel go
through things go storyboards deep Dives
Etc but this was the pandemic and we
weren't able to do that so so we really
had to rely on you know teams meetings
and zoom meetings and that was a new way
of working that a lot of our staff had
to get used to and get comfortable with
especially the leadership
some leadership at our company in
particular had to get used to the fact
that they couldn't actually go there and
actually
speak to somebody directly and looked
them in the eye and shake their hand and
and do that bonding we had to rely on
the virtual meetings
um so that was challenging but the way
we got around that is we scheduled a lot
of meetings we had a lot of a lot of
touch points set up between leadership
and the working teams
um and Etc to go through things so so
that worked really well
but one of the things that that we
learned or what I learned during the
process was
the contracts that we have set up with
the CMOS contracts generally are set up
you know to reflect how many
manufacturing runs you're going to do
how many runs am I going to do in 2022
how many are you going to do in 2023
um what you know how much of a facility
am I going to use and that's the way
your contracts are set up and then and
then you set up other you know money in
the contract for
or like you know inspections or
regulatory preparation of regulatory
documentation Etc
um but the contracts the way they were
set up didn't have enough
time didn't have enough actually money
and resources and and Personnel
Resources set aside for um for all this
we were doing so um
so we had to
um you know on the Fly sort of
renegotiate those contracts and build in
more time and build in more um
availability from the company and so
that was that's a call out to anybody
you know looking to go in the future of
what to do
um especially during this virtual
setting is that you may you may need
more support
um so anyway that was just a interesting
learning that surprise that we had
so
again prior to the inspection so we at
this point we have we've filed two Blas
with with the agency they've been
accepted they've
um and now they're now they're in the
review stage the agency has already
contacted us saying you know setting up
you know when they're going to come and
start inspecting these uh facilities
they want to know when we've been
manufacturing Etc
um so so that's all happening but as as
this is all working in the background we
start to receive
um in information requests
um and we received a lot
um we have two products so I mean let's
let's be honest there are two products
so you're going to get a lot of
questions
um and there was some redundancy of the
questions between the products you could
one question could answer another uh
product as well
um but there was a lot they weren't and
um
and as you know people working with the
FDA you get a question especially CMC
questions
um and there's multi multi-part
questions so you get one question you
say well I got one question but then
there's like 10 parts to it there's an A
B C D E F Etc
um so this these questions were quite
involved and 75 of them were
um CNC questions so it was uh there was
a lot of information we had to go
through and of those of those questions
of the 75 percent that were CMC
questions
you know about 30 of them required CMO
support there was a lot of information
that we had to get from the CMO and uh
and we had a quick turnaround we had to
turn these around and generally in one
week time or less
um so the the learning here is that or
the the call out I would say to anybody
is you need to establish a process a
process
um early with the CMO of how who's going
to be on this team to respond to the
questions who's the joint rapid team
who's
um how are you going to align on on
sharing the questions aligning on the
response to the questions and then
getting approval for the questions
because you have to have both companies
approve the questions
um and so that meant that we have to
have a lot again more meetings a lot of
meetings a lot of weekly touch points to
make sure that we're getting what we
need when we need it in a timely manner
and that we can respond to the agency uh
you know as appropriately
um to to give them the information that
they're requesting and again the thing
to hear was surprising was the amount of
and we'll get into more detail about
this but the amount of uh CMO
information that they were requesting
they were asking a lot more information
about the facility than we were
expecting and so uh so that meant we had
a lot of Engagement with the CMO
um
and uh so again met a lot a lot of
meetings a lot of coordination
um
this again happened during covid nothing
really would have changed during covid
in in this situation face-to-face
meetings when the nationality they could
have helped
um but considering the time frame of how
quickly these things were turning around
um I don't think it really made a
difference and the only thing would have
made a difference is if we had somebody
who was on site at the facility but that
was challenging to get somebody on site
at the facilities just to help
coordinate on the responses but the
meetings did work and and everything did
you know at the end everything did come
out well so
so
what did um you know what did the FDA
want what did they what were they asking
for this is like you know the details of
some of the uh
information requests that they had
so one thing that they asked for
um was provide copies of the commercial
batch records and um well what I thought
was unusual about this is that it's not
surprising that they ask for commercial
back
asked for them before they showed up at
the site
um and so this made it a little bit
challenging so again it was information
request and he said you know give us you
know copies of your commercial batch
records
um and this made a little bit
challenging with um the CMO and actually
any manufacturer because they don't like
to finalize batch records and send them
out
um or commercial batch records until
they're finalized and they're actually
not finalized until the application is
approved so it's a little bit of a
chicken in the hen the chicken and the
eggs sort of scenario where um they
don't want it they're they're waiting
for for it to be all done before they
finalize them but then the agency wants
them ahead of time
um and this also pretty
created a little bit of a dilemma with
the CMOS some of the CMOS or one of the
CMOS in particular
um because they had an issue with
Version Control they had used they were
using the same product number for the
clinical and Commercial
um material and they didn't want to
publish uh commercial batch records and
then because we were still manufacturing
clinical material and then
accidentally you know manufacture
clinical material with the commercial
batch records so um it just presented a
little bit of logistical challenges
um and it was just surprising to us how
early they wanted this not that they
wanted the commercial batch records but
just how soon they wanted them
um
the other thing that the agency asked a
lot about was our analytical method Sops
and our method transfer reports
um again this isn't too surprising but
what made it challenging for us and this
is just a call out to anybody who's
working in this field is keep good
records of of why you changed you know
methods uh you know why you went from
one method to another method what was
the rationale the reasoning
um when you did when you transferred
from one early clinical site to another
uh clinical site or testing site
um you know how did you validate or how
did you not validate but how did you
ensure that the results coming from that
one facility were the same at the next
facility
and um and we weren't necessarily all
very good at keeping those records early
on so it was challenging and then the
other thing challenging is that you're
going back in time and you have a lot of
turnover so with a lot of turnover a lot
of new people
it's hard recreating that uh
institutional knowledge of why we did
things
um so just to call out to you know keep
good records and some companies are
better at it than other companies that
just FYI
um
the next one they asked for a lot about
was
um
raw materials both critical and
non-critical raw materials and this this
I found was particularly
um interesting because I think it's
really came out of the pandemic and as
you know with the pandemic we had two
issues that caused us supply chain
issues or supply issues one was we had
some uh materials which were being
scarfed up by um
by you know vaccine manufacturers or by
hospitals that were using them because
they were they were coming to the front
of the line for
um covid activities so if it was covid
related and you know related to
manufacturing a vaccine or you're
supporting patients or things like that
those institutions and and companies
went to the front of the line to get the
supplies and then it left the rest of us
trying to scramble to find material
um so that was one and the other one is
that we know during the pandemic it
really just disrupted the supply chain
um routes you know the getting material
from Asia over to us and Etc or you know
from anywhere wherever it was coming
from
um and so uh the agency uh is very aware
of this and uh and they said they wanted
they asked very detailed questions about
you know how are you going to ensure
Supply if we approve you how are you
going to make sure that you get
um that you can continue manufacturing
um and um
so that was um just something to be
aware of is that you know they're very
aware of of the supply chain Supply
constraints out there so if you have
issues with you know sourcing some
materials
um have a plan of what you're going to
do to respond to the agency if they ask
you about that
um a couple of other things they were
asking for were cfas for all raw
materials
um this wasn't so surprising to me
because if if you dealt with the EMA EMA
ask for a lot of CMA so I was used to
this but I do think that this is
possibly in response to the supply
issues they they want to know where your
where you're sourcing your raw materials
from and who your vendors are so they
wanted to see everything and again when
they were talking about raw materials
they were talking about everything they
were talking about you know bags and um
you know bags and bottles and tips and
um and even you know as well as reagents
and as well as you know critical raw
materials so they were talking about
everything
um the other thing that they asked for
which was again surprising was uh
commercial shipping I said sop
um the commercial shipping SLP
for us doesn't it it's not necessarily
surprising because we're shipping
patient cells from one place to the next
and they want to make sure that you know
from a safety perspective how are they
how are we ensuring that the you know
the material is safe Etc so that makes
sense
um but it just reminds me
um and we'll get into a little bit I'll
touch on a little bit later but just
reminds me when they start asking for
Sops it's like
um when I first started in regulatory
um the agency when they when you would
do a submission they would ask for all
your Sops they would ask for everything
and so this reminded me of this where
they're sort of going backwards and
they're saying Hey give us give us all
your Sops give us everything so it's
just a call out just interesting
um okay
oh additionally
um they asked for
um again this is the facility
information additionally they ask for a
lot of facility information so they
asked about raw material qualification
program they asked about the aseptic uh
process simulation data and results
equipment and cleaning validations
environmental monitoring environmental
monitoring was big they asked they asked
for to know what the excursions were
during your APS runs or during your PPQ
runs
and so anyway so they asked for a lot of
information from the facility and again
this was
all prior to setting foot on the
facility so this was a little bit
unusual and again it may be a situation
where the agency was trying to
sort of do a virtual visit and handle it
that way as opposed to doing
um you know getting this information on
site at the time when they did that
inspection
so the inspection so um it wasn't the
day of there was this each of these
inspections was basically a five-day
inspection at each facility
um both sites were inspected in 2021
there was a small on-site presence from
from us because we you know because of
coveted restrictions at the facility we
just couldn't have a large uh
contingency of people there
um so we did decide decide to create
essentially a war room
um at a facility that was or at a hotel
that was very close to the manufacturing
facility so we were very close in
proximity and time zone to everything
that was taking place at the facility
um so we did that
um
as I said oh the inter this is another
interesting thing
um they the agency agreed that we had
two products being manufactured at a
facility and generally they would come
in and inspect each product separately
but they agreed to uh
they agreed to inspect
each facility one time for both products
so they just wanted to see one of our
products being manufactured and they
figured the other product was
manufactured in a similar manner so that
it would be representative of it
um and then the other thing that they
did so anyway so they combined the
inspections so rather than having
possibly four inspections two
inspections at each site we only had two
inspections and then the other thing
they did at the drug substance drug
product manufacturer is they combined a
GMP inspection and a pli inspection into
one and so I found this interesting
because
it's been my experience in the past that
the agency has taken as many
opportunities as they can to come in and
inspect a facility and really get get in
there see what's going on and make sure
that they're you know complying with the
CFR
um and here we have a situation where
they uh easily agreed to combining
inspections on several occasions and
that may be a reflection of
of the pandemic and they didn't want to
spend too much time at the facility and
they knew it was challenging or it may
be uh it may have just been coincidence
I don't know which but um but it could
be a combination of the fact that or it
could be a result of the of the pandemic
itself
um and then lastly the CMO led the you
know this the inspection the inspection
lasted about five days there were no
major observations at either facility
um
and uh so that was good
um an overview of the inspection itself
um it was uh the inspection itself was
Heavy GMP Focus
um very light product questions so we
got maybe like 10 of the questions we
had during the inspection were product
related and those were focused around
product release but the majority of
everything else was was GMP focused
questions so
um focusing on the
sorry apologies um Quality Management
Systems lens Inventory management
traceability Inventory management again
I felt that they were really harping on
the inventory management system
particularly because they're worried
about the supply chain issues
um and and they really wanted to know
how the facilities are making sure that
they have product you know basically
have they have all the raw materials and
everything they need to manufacture
um the other things that they focused on
for us were traceability chain of
identity in particular and that makes
sense again because we're we're using
human cells we're giving them back to
the patients so they want to make sure
they want to know what the traceability
is uh the chain of identity and make
sure that everything is being done
correctly the other questions they had
were about capacity planning they wanted
to know at the facility itself you know
how are you going to handle uh
commercial manufacturing do you have the
person you know capacity for personnel
do you have the capacity do you need
another site you can open up another you
know room to manufacturer Etc so they
ask questions about that
and then another interesting one which
was kind of funny they asked a lot of
questions about container closure
Integrity testing and this one caught us
off a surprise we're like why are they
asking these questions
um and it turned out that um one of our
bag manufacturers who had a dnf with the
FDA had pulled their DMF so the FDA
couldn't get information that they were
looking for so they came to us for the
information and we learned we said oh
the dmf's been pulled and so we actually
had to go to the manufacturer get all
the information from them and then give
it to the FTA so it all worked out but
it was at first it was a little strange
like why are they asking all these
questions but
um well we didn't know that our bag
manufacturer had retracted its DMF
so
all right so
takeaways or Lessons Learned so
getting to the end here
um
lessons learned from the from the from
the whole uh endeavor
um the FDA is looking for a very
granular Blas
um they they want a lot of information
in the Blas and if they're not getting
in the Blas they're actually using the
IRS to to
for even additional information
um and this is okay but
um and it's just fine I mean the FDA
obviously can ask whatever it wants and
we need to provide it
um but you know going back to my earlier
statement I like to be prepared so I
like to know you know know what the FDA
is going to be asking and what they want
from us and uh and I've always aired on
the side of giving the FDA just enough
so that they can you know they can ask
questions but you know not so much that
you're you're burdened with information
requests and uh so my you know one of my
fears is if you give FDA everything
they're going to ask all these questions
if you give them too much they're going
to just keep on asking these questions
and it's like If You Give a Mouse a
Cookie You Give a Mouse a Cookie the
mouse is going to say well how about
some milk and then you give the mouse
some milk and the milk and the mouse is
going to say well I need to I need a nap
kit now to wipe the milk off my chin and
they just keep asking these questions so
you don't want to give them too much you
want to have a balance
um but it's challenging if you don't
know where the bar is you don't know
where what the FDA is
um is asking so
um
need to learn in the future from the
agency is where their bar is you know
what what what are they what do they
really want
um rather than continuing to answer all
these IRS
um but so the agency has provided some
new guidance
um and and they I think the last one
that came out was March for Gene
therapies but um but we need to we need
some more we need we need a little bit
more granular detail about what they're
looking for so the industry should
continue to
um ask the agency to continue to update
its uh guidances so that we can
understand so we can prepare and prepare
understand what they're what they're
asking for
so
um all right
and then um and then takeaways takeaways
from from this experience uh plis
continue to focus you know heavily on
quality and and GMP
um not
the plis don't Focus as much on the
product related questions
um the product related questions are
definitely coming through the majority
of the IRS so they're using IRS to get a
lot of the product related information
and it appears that they're asking for a
lot more information so that they
um don't have to spend as much time on
site and at the sites and that might be
related to covid
um or you know the pandemic or it might
be related to
um you know gene therapy they they just
they're looking for more information
the agency in this situation the agency
was willing to combine a lot of
inspections so they so they reduced the
amount of time that they were at the
facilities
um so you know the inspect there's
they're doing fewer inspections at least
in our case they did fewer inspections
and um and they were very multi-purpose
uh inspections so that's been a that's a
little bit of new
um to this
uh new for me and new for this area so
so we'll see if that continues moving
forward and as we move from post
pandemic hopefully from post pandemic
um and then
and then from and then this is new the
FDA wants a lot more facility
information than than you know than I'm
used to
um they're they're asking for you know
raw material qualification aseptic
processing simulation all the
information around that equipment and
cleaning validations
you know facility
facility and utilities environmental
monitoring Etc
another big thing that they asked for
were deviations deviation write-ups and
and you know a lot of details there
that's not unusual for the agency to ask
about deviations but they even wanted
deviations on the minor things so they
wanted us to do write-ups on the minor
deviations all the deviations so they
wanted everything
um and I did think that that was uh for
me this is a new experience
um they previously asked for you know it
you expect them to ask you about the
deviations the complex deviations the
product related deviations or deviations
are related to facilities or things like
that and give them the information and
details but they were asking about every
all the deviations so that was just
interesting the learning that we had
all right
[Applause]
all right so uh so wrapping up
um
so wrapping up here I just you know in
summary you'll say that you know the
inspection you know we're an ex Vivo
gene therapy
um company
um we had two products and two sites
that were inspected
um the agencies that were involved were
sieber otat and uh you know dmpq
division
it was a pli and a GMP inspection as I
said inspection learnings there was
extensive use of IRS for facility
information
then step foot in the facility
um it reminds me of
like I don't know if I said this before
but it reminds me of
back in the early days of
when you we had
um
protein Therapeutics and we had
monoclonal antibodies in the early days
of protein Therapeutics and monoclonal
antibodies the agency asked for
everything they asked for a lot of
information and this is reminding me
gene therapy is reminding me of the same
thing that they're sort of going back in
time and they're asking for everything
um so that's where it would be helpful
to get some more guidance from the
agency about what they're looking for
but it reminds me of that whether
they're just asking for everything Sops
all this information the facilities Etc
so the in-depth facility information and
and particularly they're also asking
because of covid right now because of
the pandemic you know raw materials and
Supply constraints
um the other things we learned is um
it's been very challenging with the
um during the pandemic with the travel
restrictions the restrictions that the
facilities themselves and then having
the need to you know replace uh
face-to-face meetings with virtual
meetings that was a
that was a challenge it was a new way of
working for a lot of us and uh and that
presented a lot a lot of challenges it
was just hard not being able to go to
the facility as often as we would like
to and engage with them
um the other thing that
occurred during this pandemic is
absenteeism it could have been
absenteeism due to you know people being
sick and being being out sick or
absenteeism also because we had a lot of
high turnover during in the industry at
the time so the the call out here is
that
you know going into all of this has had
identified who your team is and then
identify the backups and the backups of
the backups because you definitely don't
know when you're going to need them and
you want to have that all planned out
ahead of time so so really
um build out your team and then and then
know who the backups are and who the
backup backups are
um so that when you have either turnover
or you have people who are sick or out
um you can quickly pivot and adapt so
um and the problems that we're seeing I
believe that the FDA is seeing the same
thing so the challenge is that we're
seeing with turnover the challenges
we're seeing with um covid absenteeism
the agency is seeing as well and that
may be
that may be influencing some of the
questions that they're asking us because
you may be getting new reviewers
involved and Etc but anyway it's just
something to think about
um and that really that's that's about
it so
um so I want to thank you for your time
and uh I'll pause here and um take any
questions that you have and uh thank you